okay guys it's psychobabble doing
challenge to and black hood it's a
knowledge economy okay welcome to your
second challenge in this level you will
need to achieve a goal condition succeed
okay it acknowledges support blocks like
offices okay 8 10 units of knowledge I'm
so knowledgeable so this is not a
problem for me let's see here now the
first thing we need to has had a little
Stalock economy okay just money consumer
okay so before we kill anyone let's just
walk and do some trainees real quick
okay yeah we need some [ __ ] water and
it's a [ __ ] water and then we need
some [ __ ] electricity there we go and
I hot as babies and I ha hi guys so
let's do some [ __ ] let's do some let's
do some schooling baby lets you some
school like okay baby now we got to
connect this [ __ ] you gotta connect
this bit oh [ __ ] sorry here's snare here
yeah you like that baby you like that Oh
God okay I see you have all the stuff
you need now now let's make some [ __ ]
work okay um let's say now we need a
[ __ ] let's do school first you know
and then look what a chet chet say and
then once they graduate they can move up
in the world and just go right next to
that is just family
yeah it is isn't it are we go way for
them to fell out we have enough
electricity no we're in the negative
right now that's okay baby that's okay
oh [ __ ] forgot oh [ __ ] i'm getting
[ __ ] dizzy can't we go here we go
elektrische you should be going up now
come on gallon anymore set point for
point [ __ ] we're good [ __ ] youth how
do we get some [ __ ] you anymore you
thought we know we don't really care
about youth oh that sounds horrible to
say of course we can write yes but not
for this mission knowledge we have
enough knowledge yes oh we don't have
enough to use how do we get [ __ ]
youth
okay we got to destroy these guys let's
make some real [ __ ] you okay babies
okay Jenny says [ __ ] ok now we don't
have enough [ __ ] leisure so we gotta
fix that okay I'm gonna accept tell you
later yeah we still have labor
[ __ ] we need my labor okay one sec we'll
fix this [ __ ] gettin [ __ ] dizzy um
there okay so I'm actually going to make
an elevator sweetie more labor right
here nope [ __ ] we did it okay well the
guys thank you